[Applause]
um good morning I'm Jade Rosen from
K introduction out of 339 KS pug 150
students visited the mod
724 flags were positioned on the models
presenting
ideas impact on
KBS the earthquake damaged to K Kaio
Community brought
40 a 30 to 40%
decrease in students in C
School our Focus Capo West we focused on
the Capo West area because it is near
next to
scho what we agree with one we support
the proposed business
uses two we like the idea of General a
general Park area three we support the
idea of elra car parking our concerns
our students wanted food and bdes in the
business area we don't think this is a
good idea because one the school
encourage students to ditch
school two traffic congestion as it is
aan Street in this area with only one
way in and out three this could also
encourage unhealthy eating four open
planting careful planning needs to be
visual from the street as this
Recreation space is very close to our
school and could be used by students
coming and going to school five
vandalism needs to keep looking
our idea is one natural shade and
part two public
toilets three bench
seats and fin
rubbish that's all we'
got